victime en iran la condition de la femme
à la mode des ayatollahs la deuxième
promotion de femmes policières a été
présentée à téhéran fusil en bandoulière
mais tchador sur les cheveux laurent
boussier descente en rappel course
poursuite en voiture tir et simulation
d'arrestations la démonstration se veut
efficace même si le port du tchador la
rend parfois délicat entre la morale
islamique qui interdit aux hommes de
fouiller ou deux mots noté des femmes et
la nécessité de faire face à
l'augmentation des crimes commis par ces
dernières
voici donc la deuxième promotion de
police iranienne
ce n'est pas seulement la politesse qui
me fait dire que les femmes sont plus
motivés plus honnête plus scientifique
plus précises quand elles font ce
travail c'est le brigadier qui le dit
prestation de serment à la république
islamique tchador et fusils d'assaut
ces jeunes filles formées pendant quatre
ans comme leurs collègues masculins sont
contraintes de porter ce long voile noir
qui les recouvre de la tête aux pieds
je suis affirmatif
nous pouvons faire tout ce qu'un homme
peut faire nous pouvons descendre en
rappel sur un immeuble seulement nous
devons porter le tchador
alors que les hommes eux le font en
uniforme ce qui est plus facile après
plus de 25 ans d'interdiction mettait le
policier cette deuxième promotion est un
pas en avant dans la très lente
émancipation des femmes iraniennes
aux dernières nouvelles un tchador
spéciale serait même à l'étude pour
rendre plus facile les courses
poursuites dans les rues de téhéran
une dernière image à l'étranger celle de